the governor of Russia's kosk region
says a drone has attacked an Airfield
setting an oil storage tank on fire the
region borders Ukraine and the incident
comes a day after multiple explosions at
two military bases deeper inside Russian
territory Moscow blamed Ukrainian drones
for those blasts Kiev has not claimed
responsibility
on Monday Russia launched another wave
of strikes against Ukrainian cities
President Vladimir solenski says
missiles killed at least four people and
knocked out power in many parts
Ukrainian officials are warning several
regions are now facing more emergency
blackouts
let's get more on this latest escalation
in the war from
he's an analyst with the security and
defense program in Budapest first of all
tell us more about these blasts that
Moscow blame on Ukraine uh we're getting
reports of further supposed drone
strikes in Russia what what do you make
of all of this
well we need to differentiate between
different targets and different blasts
the two blasts which occurred very far
away from Ukraine's border at the Angus
air base and the jaguilevo air base
these are two air bases deep inside
Russia uh where Russia is uh using this
is the home basis for Russia's strategic
bombers which are used against uh which
are used for the attacks against Ukraine
the attacks on these bases even if they
were done by Ukraine Ukraine hasn't
claimed responsibility even if the
attacks were done by Ukraine and
Ukrainian drones then these drones would
probably be were launched from Russia by
by some Ukrainian special agent Special
Operations because these bases are very
far away from Ukraine's border Ukraine
doesn't have drones of that range the
very center attack against the Cruz
region that was probably done by a
Ukrainian drone launched from Ukraine
what these attacks means that Ukraine is
clearly capable of hitting military
targets deep inside Russia's territory
and the Russian bases neighboring
Ukraine the Russian bases in the regions
which are neighboring Ukraine are
clearly in danger in the long run if
these attacks continue Russia is highly
likely to withdraw its Air Forces to
Bases further away from the Ukrainian
border which might hamper the operation
of Russia's Russian Air Forces
but does this signal an escalation in
this Ward you think from these few
attacks
I'm not entirely sure about that I mean
in the last 11 months of the War uh or
nearly the last 11 months of the war
there have been several cases when
Ukraine was able to attack Russian
territory not only and occupied Crimea
but also military bases inside Russia so
these attacks do not signal much of an
escalation either in terms of targeting
or in terms of intensity I don't think
this is a sign of an escalation I think
this is more a sign of Ukraine's
building next to fight back and also hit
deep Russian territory should give deem
it necessary but I don't see an
escalatory pattern here okay Andres just
let me play this next report because I
want to ask you about uh Russia's
launching of a new wave of missile
attacks on Monday they caused widespread
power outages and damages uh across the
region to infrastructure
Keith residents seeking shelter in the
city's Metro stations
it's not the first time they've had to
flee underground for safety from Russian
missiles
but the impact of these strikes is
getting more severe as temperatures drop
for sure
I hope there won't be mass destruction
the Russians waited until temperatures
fell to five six degrees Celsius
until it got cold
but we have blankets
sleeping bags
I believe we will endure it even if they
inflict some destruction today
[Music]
Ukraine's Air Force says it shot down
more than 60 of the 70 missiles launched
President Vladimir zielinski hailed The
Defenders I want to thank the Air
Defense Forces our electrical engineers
and our people the Air Defense Forces
shot down most of the missiles the
engineers have already begun to restore
electricity our people never give up
glory to Ukraine
repeated Russian missile and drone
strikes have targeted the power grid
leaving Millions without electricity and
Heating
ukrainians have resorted to wood stoves
to fend off the cold
the Kremlin wants to weaponize Winter to
bring Ukraine to its knees
this has been happening time and again
over weeks now
using winter as a weapon I mean at all
amounts to a war crime doesn't it
most probably yes I mean systematically
attacking clearly civilian targets it is
something that can well be qualified as
a war crime this has actually been part
of Russia's warfighting strategy for a
long time I mean attacking civilian
infrastructure was an integral part of
how Russia fought the first chachan war
the second chachan war even its air air
campaign in in Syria so what Russia air
forces are doing now I mean by attacking
Ukrainian civilian infrastructure on the
one hand it's a war crime on the other
hand however not much new at taking into
account Russia's previous war
unfortunately
are there any other strategies that the
Russians are going to be able to come up
with it sounds like they're quite
desperate
and they seem to be quite desperate
because the Russian ground forces have
lost initiative on the front line
already like a late late summer so these
systematic attacks against Ukrainian
civilian infrastructure appear to be a
strategy aimed at weaponizing the winter
and the Ukrainian winter is much harsher
than the winter we have in Germany uh so
the the strategy seems to be the
weaponized the winter to break the
morale of the Ukrainian civilian
population however again I mean military
history doesn't know too many examples
when the morale of the civilian
population could be broken solely by
aerial bombing so here I've shared the
optimism of president president zelinski
I think Ukrainian population will endure
other threats of the security and
defense program in Budapest thank you
very much for giving us your analysis
thank you
Nick Connelly is our correspondent in
Keith Nick Ukrainian drones are reported
to have hit two Russian air bases in its
territory that would have the potential
to escalate things what do we know
exactly
well since yesterday we have seen a
whole lot more in terms of images of the
Damage Done initially we just had you
know kind of CCTV footage from nearby
buildings you know of a bang we saw a
big flame on the night sky in the design
one of those bases and since then we've
had pictures of the damage also from the
sky from satellite seeing from above
what was done
um the explosion of that petrol tanker
and signs of also damage to some of the
crews there and now in the last few
hours this morning there seems to have
been another attack on Russian territory
this time somewhat close to the
Ukrainian border the city of korsk about
100 kilometers away from Ukraine's
Frontiers which is still a lot deeper
inside Russia than has been kind of the
norm through this war where mostly
basically kind of 20 30 kilometers deep
into Russia so it's like Belgrade close
to kharkiv have seen Ukrainian
retaliation so this does seem like a
real changing gear it seems like Ukraine
now capable of doing this we'd heard
yesterday even from the Russians that
they thought this was a Soviet drone
which immediately didn't kind of really
make sense and it wasn't something that
kind of computed and now it seems that
potentially there is room for the
ukrainians to have rebuilt re-engineered
as it were a Soviet surveillance drone
that basically is redundant now because
the electronics and the Optics just
aren't up to Modern standards you have
kind of commercial satellites and
basically turn that drone into a kind of
Kamikaze drone that then takes
explosives deep into Russian territory
but with kind of a good engine as it
were obviously this is all unconfirmed
but it does it sort of seem to uh you
know make sense to lots of experts in
the field but obviously all the more
embarrassing for Russia that it is
unable to destroy and detect drones that
it itself built 30 40 50 years ago and
that they're able to fly so deep into
Russian territory unnoticed and
unstopped especially as some of those
bases hit yesterday those are places
where Russia bases its nuclear deterrent
so these are kind of as strategic as you
know as sites as they get and that that
is not something that Russia is able to
properly defend is something that's
going to be obviously very worrying and
very embarrassing development Putin and
President floresolenski says Ukraine
shot down most of the missiles Russia
fight yesterday but the latest barrage
still caused serious damage I guess
that's definitely the case I think it
really depends where in Ukraine you are
here in the capital key of obviously the
defenses are a little better so there
was less in the way of hits especially
in key of City some of the outers of
power seem to have been a kind of
precaution by the Ukrainian authorities
to prevent further damage basically
drawing systems down switching them off
temporarily while those missile attacks
were being expected and in lot space
they were able to then restart them
realistically quickly but in places like
Odessa and Goliath in the south of
Ukraine close to the Sea those outages
are still continuing and it has been
said by experts that it is just a lot
more difficult because they are close to
the Sea you know it's much more
difficult to detect drones
and obviously missiles or any kind of
attack over the scene just fewer radar
uh installations there so basically it's
easier to surprise Ukraine's Defenders
and Ukraine's anti-aircraft systems in
regions by the sea uh but uh I think
broadly every time we have these attacks
Ukraine is able to knock more of these
missiles out of the sky and recover
slightly faster so there is definitely
progress there Nick Connelly thank you
very much for the reporting from Keith